How do you determine what is truthful?
What's reliable?
What you're gonna believe in?
What's forming your world to you?
Let's go around the horn again to wrap this. Well,
like from information
I might like look at the sources of like
who is this information speaking from
and like by looking at their background
I might I could like judge how like
how could zero experience it
or views like influence of reliability of the text.
If something sounds unbelievable,
I'll double check it on Google most likely
where you'll see more trustworthy sources. Okay.
And trustworthy sources
are either filling with particular brands. Yeah,
like Washington Post,
New York Times, um,
see you then. Okay. Okay.
That mean I usually just for Thai news,
um, I usually listen to the radio
in the car when I come to school
and if it's like
something that I see on Instagram or things like that,
then I usually like
double check with an unbiased new source outside.
I think it's brilliant
that you guys have the presence of mind and the wisdom
where you are at this
young stage in life to be thinking it through that way.
And I really want to appreciate you for your candor
and your frankness and your
openness about the topic that is front and center
and it's really important
to everybody in the world today.
And as I mentioned
you off camera before we began,
you guys are gonna be leading the solution.
So We're relying on you,
and we thank you very much for
sharing your thoughts today.
Thank you. Thank you as well.